economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos en américa
latina' en argentina específicamente
subieron los precios al consumidor y
hubo protestas por supuesto santiago muy
buenas noches mire cientos de
trabajadores se tomaron las calles de
buenos aires para exigir un aumento del
salario mínimo también asistencia social
y más acciones gubernamentales para
proteger los empleos afectados por la
pandemia el salario mínimo de este país
santiago es de casi 17 mil pesos
argentinos es decir un poco más de 200
dólares y lo que han pedido los
manifestantes es que lo triplican a
cerca de 600 dólares la protesta
coincide con la revelación hoy del dato
de inflación a septiembre los precios
subieron un 36 6% frente al mismo
período del año pasado principalmente
por un aumento en los combustibles y por
las tensiones cambiarias la inflación se
daba en un contexto de recesión y
también a pocas semanas de que se
revelara que la pobreza en 2019 afectaba
a 3
10 ciudadano santiago no es fácil el
panorama económico de argentina daniela
la comisión europea dio un primer paso
para retirar todos estos productos
químicos que son peligrosos en la
fabricación de juguetes si el bloque de
27 países se está alistando para
prohibir una serie de químicos que
afectan los sistemas inmunológico y
respiratorio estos están presentes en
productos como juguetes cosméticos y
detergentes entre otros
europa ya tiene una de las leyes más
estrictas del mundo sobre productos
químicos esto hay que decirlo tiene por
ejemplo prohibida una amplia gama de
sustancias cancerígenas en juguetes y en
envases de alimentos pero el próximo año
irá más allá e incluirá cientos de otras
sustancias que pueden también afectar el
sistema reproductivo hay algunas que por
ejemplo no se descomponen cuando
ingresan al cuerpo humano santiago
estos materiales tóxicos no sólo podrían
o sólo podrán ser usados si se demuestra
que son estrictamente esenciales
volvemos a américa latina' daniela el
propietario de la empacadora de carne
más grande del mundo fue sentenciado y
fue declarado culpable de soborno
por lo que pasó santiago estamos
hablando de jf investimentos que es el
conglomerado que en su momento también
fue dueño del fabricante de las muy
famosas sandalias havaianas hoy se
declaró culpable en un tribunal federal
de eeuu de pagar más de 150 millones de
dólares en sobornos entre 2005 y 2017 el
fbi detalló que como parte de este
esquema los ejecutivos de los niveles
más altos de la empresa utilizaron
bancos y bienes raíces estadounidenses
para pagar decenas de millones de
dólares en sobornos a funcionarios
corruptos en brasil esto con el fin de
obtener cientos de millones de dólares
en financiamiento para la empresa y sus
afiliadas como parte del acuerdo de
conciliación esta compañía que tiene más
de 250.000 empleados en 190 países
aceptó pagar una multa de 256 millones
de dólares a las autoridades tanto
estadounidenses como brasileñas
daniela cuéntenos cómo es que los
grandes bancos de eeuu mantuvieron
ganancias a pesar de la incertidumbre
económica que no
en santiago entre enero y septiembre de
este año si bien ninguno acumuló
pérdidas sus ganancias y fueron menores
a las del mismo período del año pasado
el banco más grande de haití morgan por
ejemplo vio como sus utilidades bajaron
en un 39 por ciento en estos nueve meses
bank of america ganó 41 por ciento menos
wells fargo por su parte el tercer banco
más grande apenas ganó 309 millones en
todo este período y citigroup redujo sus
beneficios a la mitad todos estos bancos
santiago tuvieron que hacer millonarias
provisiones en sus cajas porque
recordemos que muchos de los deudores no
han podido pagar sus créditos esa fue la
fórmula indicadores fueron justamente
esos resultados de la gran banca los que
hicieron que wall street cerrará en rojo
por segunda jornada consecutiva en
europa hubo resultados dispares todo
porque los inversionistas no ven
claridad en estímulos y por la evolución
de la pandemia y en américa latina se
destaca el repunte de argentina de casi
un 3% el día de hoy y a la base de
brasil por segundo día consecutivo y
para el cierre
bueno son los doce mil en millones de
dólares que aprobó el banco mundial para
que los países en desarrollo puedan
comprar y distribuir la vacuna de 19
este organismo estima que el dinero
facilitará la vacunación de hasta 1000
millones de personas en estos países
pero no solamente la vacuna el dinero
también se usará para financiar pruebas
y tratamientos muchas gracias daniela es
todo en la economía en france24 siga con
nosotros
i